did you know that you can be an
accomplice to a hacker attack while
watching a movie in 2022 the number of
botnet attacks reached a record high
botnet is a large number of computers
infected with single malware controlled
remotely by hackers they're also called
zombies these zombies can number in the
millions their purpose to carry out
hacking attacks like spreading malware
spamming stealing personal data and
Performing DDOS attacks and you cannot
not notice it for a very long time
because they act covertly the main signs
are the computer's slowing down unknown
processes in the task manager eat up
memory or CPU resources and parasitic
traffic so what do you do disconnect
from the internet and scan with an
antivirus up-to-date database preferably
from an external drive like a USB and to
prevent it in future one use antivirus
two use antivirus three at least use an
antivirus and be safe